[Music]
you look good jeremy fantastic thank you
sir so do you both of you do thank you i
have to say i like the suit i like the
glasses the the uh the beard is great
the mustache yes i know this is for your
part mr selfridge but then it's got the
little twist at the end which looks
evil it's fantastic right
i you know what i look very hip here
here's what's happening
i'm old and i need glasses right that's
number one so i have this hipster
situation going on up top right right
and then i've got the hipster mustache
but it's for a roll it's for a roll
right so i'm the only guy that's legit
out there at this at this moment there's
there's nothing hip about me it's just
it's functional yeah what i'm saying
this is functional like the other guys
out there because you see them around
they've got a micro brew that they made
themselves right they're in their
pajamas they're in their pajamas
they make their own comic book on the
side and they have the weird twist in
the mustache but yours is legit this is
legit and it looks fantastic now let's
talk about for mr selfridge the show
which we'll talk about in a minute
you've been living in london yeah you've
been living in london like full time
living in london what is that like um
it's fantastic one day after work i
remember i threw my bags down i was so
excited because my drum set arrived and
this is all i'm going to tell a story
and i'm not playing the victim this is
my fault okay i take full responsibility
i didn't know you were a drummer you
were drunk i'm viciously mediocre as a
drummer but i love to play i love to
play so i got home and i threw my bags
down and i immediately launched into
kind of a keith moon very aggressive
session and where are we again we're in
my flat and you're flat in london
my apartment indeed and i looked up and
i'm about
36 seconds into my solo
and everyone in my building is
surrounding my drum kit screaming that
i'm killing their children yeah yeah you
can't you can't have a drum kit in an
apartment building no apparently not
what do you mean
no that's not apparently not you just
can't do that no i can't and and here's
the deal i was so excited i just didn't
know what was happening and i promised
them i would never do it again i was a
sweaty american that lived above them
and i was quiet for the rest of the time
and it sat there in my living room like
a ferrari parked without being able to
drive it right and it was very sad and i
i sobbed like a grandmother every day
looking at it that's the saddest thing
i've ever heard yeah it is wait a minute
no it's not yeah
i've heard plenty of sad things did you
uh when you're living there did you get
to meet any cool british celebrities you
know what i went to a polo match and and
and
harry and william prince harry and the
the duke of of you-know-what
um was there yeah you know you know
we're talking oh that duke yes that old
duke indeed and uh after the polo match
by the way
harry and william played ridiculously
well and
they said you know come and meet the
royals and i thought okay i'd love to to
watch other people meet the royals but
apparently i was a part of the line and
i met both of them and and prince harry
kept calling me ari
uh and
yeah and and really and he was calling
you your character name yeah just called
my character
that's sweet it was sweet and i and i
didn't want to be beheaded so i agreed
with him you know i mean i was i don't i
haven't had the authority to behead
anyone in about 600 years but i
i live in fear conan
that's what they want you to think yeah
yeah they got me man they could do it